- I love going to games,
like for the mingling and the food.
- Yes.
(Kelly chuckles)
Yes.
- And the game.
- [Mindy] You know what
my fear is about the food?
- In that order.
- Is like, I'm so worried
that when the camera,
if you have good seats,
if the camera catches you
and you're just like eating a hamburger.
- [Kelly] Mm-hmm.
- And then, a player
falls on you or something.
I just like, I just wanna seem dainty,
so I just like sip water or whatever.
- I think just early on, like,
yeah, no, I've had like the
worst photos of me taken,
like in a bathing suit,
like going down on like a big hot dog.
Like, I've had the worst photos,
like, like a wave coming up.
And I'm not like Heidi
Klum, it's just like...
(Kelly groans)
(Mindy laughs)
And it's like, you know, it's so comedic
that I just lean in and don't care.
- I feel like most of my life
is avoiding becoming a meme.
- I am 100, I don't care.
(audience and Mindy laugh)
Like, meme it up.
Like, I don't care,
I'm gonna live my life,
I'm gonna have the hot dog.
Did, did LeBron ever
notice you taking pictures?
Because you're really recognizable, so.
- Yeah, so one time I
went to a game and he,
I was sitting next to people I didn't know
and he came down and
he waved and I assumed,
like clearly that he's
waving at somebody else.
Like, why would he be waving at me?
And then I looked at the
two guys to see like,
who LeBron's friends were
and they were like, "We don't know him".
And I was like, "I think
LeBron was waving at me".
(audience chuckles)
Maybe he's a big, "The Mindy Project" fan.
We never knew.
- Wait...
- [Mindy] Yeah, so he
gave me a little wave.
- And you didn't wave back?
- No, because I didn't know it was me.
So, now he probably thinks I'm unfriendly.
- He thinks you're a snob.
(Kelly laughs)
- Because I big timed him.
So, now he'll know, because...
- [Kelly] Yeah, we're
gonna get this message out.
(audience laughs)
- I just, you know...
- She would've waved,
LeBron, she would've waved.
- I would've waved back,
I didn't wanna be...
You know, the worst feeling
is when someone waves
and you're like, "Hey".
And they're like,
"We don't care about you, it
was the person next to you".
I didn't wanna be that guy.
- Yeah, I've been that person a lot too.
I feel like I'm a lot of
what you don't wanna be.
- No, no.
(audience and Kelly laugh)
This is like...
- You know what, you
should hang out with me.
You would feel really good about yourself.
I will cover the ground
of all the other things
and I won't care.